you know when you talk about kind of the
fundamental values that drive your role
in public life you talk about in one of
your speeches equal worth responsibility
and community and mention today kind of
the what you view is universal elements
of faith kind of your connection to your
neighbors and being part of something
bigger than yourself and I think you
even acknowledge that you don't have to
be a person of faith to have those sorts
of feelings so it sounds as if you're
appealing essentially to kind of the
essential elements of the human
condition if you will and so are you
suggesting that traditions of faith can
be vehicles that help to tap into that
essential humanity that we all have so
is it really an instrument you know for
introducing the types of change we want
and and if so does encouraging faith
traditions to have a much more
significant public role doesn't that
also bring in all of the values that
aren't shared more universally you know
can you have one without the other so I
guess that's two questions in one yeah I
mean first of all yes I am saying that
that I think that faith is one way of
rooting public life in a set of clear
values to do with the human condition
and secondly I would say that yes there
is that danger but that depends on and
this is the whole purpose of the
Interfaith part of what what what I'm
about it depends on whether you express
your faith in a set of as i call it
exclusionary doctrines or whether you
express your faith in a set of
inclusionary values now that there will
instantly always be difficult questions
in relation to
this you know I've raised one today I
mean abortion which is a genuinely
difficult issue we're genuinely
difficult issue and if you bring faith
more into public life some of those
questions start to become very acute and
it's it's I think it's quite
uncomfortable for political leaders when
you know organized religions taking
positions on those types of issues in it
it can cause a lot of tension that
that's true but I think that is a and so
there will be some of that but I think
that is a relatively small price to pay
for what good can come with faith in
public life which is a sense that that
you know there is something higher and
more important that you or your
constituency actually and I suppose what
I'm really saying is that the way I
think that this this is this can be
neatly aligned it in the modern world of
globalization is that my theory is that
globalization only works if it is
infused with values of equity and
justice and so that's why I say you get
to the point of national enlightened
national self-interest meaning that you
take account of these values so if you
are taking account of those values it
actually it him it improves your your
chances of advancing the interests of
your country inn in the modern world